do you remember when that started when
you were a kid like when you first saw
your potential to Razzle Dazzle and
shine
10 years old school talent show really
yeah were you the host please tell me
the hose with like a thin little cane
and like a candy store
um I was actually gonna go out on stage
and do a um a routine with a friend of
mine where we're gonna do like a
Saturday Night Live sketch and when the
curtain opened up he got scared and he
ran out no and so the lady that was uh
putting on the audition she goes well
your friend left you is there anything
you know how to do by yourself
I said well I can do voices she goes
what do you mean and I just started
doing like impressions of cartoon
characters and stuff and they just
started looking at each other and I was
like okay and they're like okay you're
on Saturday and I'm like what no just
like that so uh I wound up going out on
stage and someone someone says the best
way to break the ice is with a joke I
said well I don't know any jokes and
someone told me a joke and I said it and
I was 10 years old I said why did the
chicken cross the road and then I said
to check out the chicks you know I never
heard that word it's uh well it's you
know for a 10 year old I was pretty
groundbreaking if you're 46 it sounds a
little creepy but
laughs
you know what to check out the chicks
and so I opened up with that and then I
just started doing these Impressions and
stuff and it just it went over well do
you remember your I have so many
questions you remember your first
impression oh God I was doing like uh
PeeWee Herman Ronald Reagan Yogi Bear
Yogi Bear uh
so you had a bunch yeah I was even doing
Bill Cosby crazy right of course
um I used to kill at church with Bill
Cosby
it was just it was just a few and I
wasn't even saying nothing funny it was
just the fact that I was doing the
voices and of course coming out of this
kid out of this adorable kid I mean
you've got so much Charisma everybody's
rooting for you the moment you walk on
stage and then you do voice like great
of course now but I imagine even then
pretty good voices the other question I
was going to ask was do you remember how
that fell did that did that mail
something man that was an incredible
feeling because I didn't I wasn't sure
what the reaction was supposed to be I
just remember I was like a big fan of
Eddie Murphy and I saw his comedy
specials and I was like oh that's cool I
like that he goes up there he he's
telling stories he's doing voices and
it's just it seemed like that I want
yeah and he's Fearless
absolutely and so um when I started
doing stand-up you know when I actually
call myself a stand-up
all I was doing was Impressions and
characters I wasn't really talking about
myself and so that took a few years for
me to get comfortable enough to share
real experiences and stories
and all I did was I just put the sound
effects and the characters and the you
know the Impressions on top of that and
so it turned all of my regular stories
into like whoa right you know what I
mean Secret Sauce so exactly so instead
of saying oh I ran to this girl and she
was crazy it's more so like yeah I ran
to this girl and she's like oh my God
and then you know like whoa I bring the
room up right right energy and the
sounds and then the back and forth do
you like Pablo because I I Pablo
actually uh I remember watching Pablo
early on I got to open this one time
yeah yeah definitely here's one of those
yeah yeah
do something with the knife that's what
I always say yeah here you go do
something with the knife here you go
hold my baby
hold my baby it's actually John Mulaney
and I still say do something with
another do something with each other
it's from what is it what show it's uh
Jerry Springer that they encourage
violence yes do something with the knife
should be giving the audience knives
Pablo actually uh is one of those guys
that you know I don't think he gets
enough credit he opened up a lot of
doors in Europe like I the reason I
started to play Europe so much is
because Pablo had gone there and he
paved the way there was promoters out
there and they're like we saw Pablo
Francisco and we wanted to bring him out
here to Europe we know he'd do good and
then apparently he was just selling out
left and right and so they're like well
you know this guy can do it well maybe
we can bring other people and so Pablo
was the first one that laid that
groundwork so once I went out there it's
like yeah this is the Pablo run I'm like
well let's do the Pablo run yeah and
also Scandinavian pictures yeah that oh
my not not the same voice you did but
that's sort of like characters it's very
character driven yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely one of the first guys that I
saw his thing about
um Linkin Park I forget we don't have to
do Pablo bets all day but like I my my
wife and I will just throw it on to
watch it where he's like they talk in
two voices it's like I don't know what
to do here here I am like they have two
modes it kills me every single time so
tell me about from being 10 in a uh
talent show
and the feeling that you got so you kind
of got hooked I got hooked when I was
10. and then and then the next time I
got a chance to go up on in front of
people was when I was in high school and
I was on the speech team and so every
dad get up in front of the class and
just tell random stories about whatever
but I was getting credit for for being
in front of the class yeah and so that's
where I got my my chops and just my my
you know being comfortable in front of
people anytime every day in front of
class I wanted you to perform that was
always such a happy thing I hated
writing I hated reading and writing and
just uh I just want to go up there and
talk yeah and even now like I don't
nothing is ever on paper nothing is ever
written not nothing's ever typed out
nothing's ever text it's just it's all
up here right I might have bullet points
for things just so I remember but I
cannot sit and write stuff out and try
to perform it like that it has to come
from here for the first time and then if
it goes well I remember and then I
reapply it I I completely agree they say
one side of your brain dictates and the
other side communicates so if you're
reciting something it's the other side
than the communicating and I see you
when you're doing your standup you're
communicating the bit you're there
you're talking to them you'll adapt yeah
it doesn't feel like it's a recite you
know okay okay here we go yeah you're
not just telling a joke that you wrote
that's like crafted obviously it's
crafted but you know what I mean like
with an exacto knife like you trim away
the the dot on there and you know what
there's some people that can do it I
just I've never had that ability and
it's not that I can't read or write it's
just that it's it's work for me and if
it's work I don't want to do it it has
to be fun before you had that outlet
and again please know that you're in in
Good Company here I was a really anxious
kid and and to this day if my wife and I
go to dinner and I can't tune out the
people around us I can't just enjoy it
she'll be like you need to do a set and
like I remember it's hard to remember
but like junior high high school what it
felt like before guys like us found a
steady Outlet was it how did that
manifest anxiety I had like health
problems digestive problems like I
needed to find a way to express myself
um you know I I only had a couple of
friends back in high school and
fortunately they're still my friends you
know and really yeah oh wow yeah
um two and I got two so you know it
worked out I chose wisely
um he has chosen I Wesley I spent most
of my time around my mom and my two
friends so I mean it was
I didn't really have moments or times
where I felt like oh what do I need I
mean I had a Nintendo I had a stereo I
had TV cable and then my two friends
and so I I felt like I was always you
know I was always okay don't get me
wrong I had I was always talking about
comedy around them they all they they
all both knew like oh he's always
talking about this like this is
something real yeah
but you felt like you were okay
a kid with two friends and a mom and a
Nintendo right like that's a kid she's
okay and you don't know you don't know
if you don't know that's what I mean
like looking back it's like do you feel
like comedy was helping pull you out of
something for me it did it did
yeah it did but I mean you know again if
if you don't know that you're not having
the best time or it's you know what's on
the other side of the wall then you know
how can you stress over it yeah
you remember
oh yeah
[Music]